why don't we go next to Melody from
misery Melody from Missouri welcome to
the program uh you've been on before
right or am I not remembering correctly
yes I'm the one who spoke about the uh
drag controversy I'm the drag king
that's right welcome
hello
um so my partner is trans and with all
these anti-trans sentiments going around
and Missouri being one around there's
actually a protest in Jeff City today
um where do you think it would be safe
for us to go that's in the South my
partner is health issues and we need to
move somewhere warm and oh man I'm kind
of like all these Southern maybe
Southwest I don't know but we're we're
kind of lost as to what to do so there's
a couple different ways to go about this
and you know it's really this has to be
your choice but if you said I want to be
in the South but somewhere that is kind
of like safer for Trans people I guess
we would say you know one of the things
that there's there's a couple things to
consider one is what laws have been
passed regarding everything from trans
bathrooms to school stuff if it's
relevant to you Etc so so like one is
like what is the legislation and then
the other thing is culturally what's
going going on and that really varies
way more within States it can vary
significantly so like for example in
Miami
my sense is that Miami itself and to
some degree probably Miami Beach
culturally are very trans friendly that
being said there are state level Florida
laws that you may see and say that I
don't like so I'm not up on all of these
details in order to be able to say Hey
you know here's where here's where you
should go but I think there's a couple
of different things to look at which
include cultural questions when there's
kids involved it's educational and other
things as well as what are the laws that
the states have passed with regard to
these issues
and we're looking at something like New
Mexico or uh Arizona possibly there's a
job I could transfer to but like yeah
Arizona is interesting Arizona is
interesting because the state has become
much more blue even though there's a lot
of crazy people there as evidenced by
the fact that that Kerry Lake almost won
but there's parts of it that are correct
correct me if I don't hold me to this
but like I think Tucson for example is
becoming quite a left-leaning city and
I've spent some time down there and
really enjoyed it so you've really got
to look at the details
well we're kind of in a blue spot in a
red state right now we're in Kansas City
so
um or which we've got lots of gay
friendly and trans-friendly places that
we go to but if you look at Missouri at
large and it's kind of getting different
thing it's the state versus local and
then the culture versus law thing yeah
listen I'm sure you will end up making
the best decision for your family but I
know it's a tough situation
thank you so much all right Melody from
Missouri
great to hear from you